bob from new york uh you're on the rich
eisen show wanting to talk about the
overtime rules how are you bob
yeah hi rich big fan long time fan but
first time caller and it's really a
thrill to speak with you
thank you very much is this the same bob
who has multiple emmy awards you told my
colleague chris brockman to shut up
yesterday is that the same bob costas uh
yeah i guess that's true
both counts bob syracuse on syracuse
crime okay
it wasn't a crime it was a good natured
shut up
there was no rancor involved in that at
all and i enjoyed yesterday's session so
much yes and i'm checking back in here
just to kind of put a ribbon around this
in terms of the argument it never ceases
to amaze me
how people can be so illogical when
they're presented with a logical
argument which doesn't mean that they
have to agree with you or me
but illogic is frustrating so a lot of
the response you see
uh over the years when something like
this happens is
well
if you can't stop
uh patrick mahomes with 13 seconds to go
you deserve to lose what does that have
to do with the validity of the rule
the rule is stupid on its face
even if josh allen and patrick mahomes
both had the ball five times the rule is
still illogical and unfair
it has nothing to do it isn't a response
to what happened on sunday night i first
said this on the air five years ago on
nbc and i said it at the beginning of
this season on hbo it wasn't about any
particular game although i did list
at least a half dozen games where
marquee quarterbacks aaron rodgers drew
brees matt ryan and his mvp year mahomes
himself in the afc championship game a
half dozen instances where marquee
quarterbacks never touch the ball
in overtime in the abstract this is a
foolish rule that is unfair and i listed
all the other reasons it takes strategy
out of the game etc and if you're gonna
amend it you have to play a timed period
and then you have people say well what
about safety well i think i was kind of
at the forefront of talking about ctv
and other and other circumstances but if
you're already playing a 17-game season
there isn't anybody that wouldn't be
willing to play an extra quarter or a
portion of a quarter if if the if
advancing in the playoffs was on the
line or if the super bowl itself was on
the line so what happened on sunday
night is just an example of how foolish
the rule is it doesn't matter if buffalo
had won the game if buffalo had stopped
kansas city on the first possession and
then and then somehow had had scored
because kansas city blew a coverage it
was their fault it doesn't matter it's
it's like saying that if in
extra innings one team got three outs
and the other team got two and then
somebody made a dopey error and the
answer was well if you can't feel the
routine ground ball what difference does
it make
think beyond the particulars of a given
game or a given moment and just look at
it in the abstract it's a bad rule on
its face and it doesn't matter what
happened on sunday night if buffalo had
won the game it's still a bad rule so
then let me just jump in here and and
and follow up when you said it's a timed
quarter because i want to get this
straightened out and and maybe even
codified bob because despite the immense
success of your career i think the
capstone would clearly be having
something called the costas rule adopted
by the national football league so
let's get to i would think so it'd be a
legacy it would be a legacy builder no
question bob um so what about this wish
so when you say a timed quarter
so what if it's tied after that then
what then do we have sudden death and
then whoever gets the ball
whoever finished the quarter would get
it for like we still haven't decided
how it's decided
who gets the ball first when sudden
death finally hits right so what is that
determinant
well you could toss a coin for who
receives if you're playing a period of
some length as i said to you yesterday i
would have the competition committee go
back
and take a look at
what period of time doesn't have to be
15 minutes maybe it's eight maybe it's
10 maybe it's 12 maybe it is 15. what
period of time
ensures
that the game plays out in something
that represents
uh in a smaller portion represents
the the essence of football
no no one would say that you should play
a one minute overtime in the nba
you play five that seems to be
that seems to be enough possessions yes
and enough of a of a microcosm of what
basketball is for it to be legitimate
but nobody would say okay the game is
over if on the first possession steph
curry hits a three-pointer but not if
they make a layup
you know and baseball put um as an
example and these aren't perfect
examples but they're worth thinking
about baseball put the ghost runner on
second base in because of covet they
wanted to get games over more quickly
when they were playing bubbles in effect
in 2020 but even in 2020 under those
circumstances they took that rule out in
the postseason because they realize that
it's gimmicky and they want
extra innings to reflect what baseball
is correct
the nfl overtime rule does not reflect
what football is and i'm totally with
you i i just again i'm just thinking
like the way that you've described it
one team gets the ball first
scores touchdown second team gets the
ball first scores a touchdown forget
about let's just even leave aside that
if you do have this construct getting
the ball second is a benefit because you
know you have to go for it from your own
20-yard line to match a touchdown or a
field goal but as opposed to getting it
first single possessions
playing if you're playing a period of
time you might decide to punt correct i
mean there are teams like with four
minutes to go in a game down by seven
four minutes to go on the fourth quarter
they punt if they have enough timeouts
right depending upon what field position
is they don't necessarily go for it
unfortunately so let's just say it's
tied or neither team scores right and
i've got the ball
for a second time the other team's only
had one possession um and so i run out
the clock to force
sudden death because i know i'm gonna
keep the ball because i have it at the
end of the first overtime period you see
what i'm saying like at some point we
still have to decide
once sudden death hits who gets to keep
it and the strategy
around it i think it would be this um
and there's an ebb and flow obviously
teams make decisions
regarding field position and time
remaining whether they want to gamble
offensively or give the ball up and and
turn it over to their defense um but i
would guess let's say you flip a coin
let's say we're going to play a 10
minute overtime period but it's timed
with all the regular dynamics of
football certain maybe give them two
timeouts maybe give them three who knows
but it reflects it's just as if it was
the last 10 minutes of a game if you
just tuned in it's just as if it was the
last 10 minutes of the fourth quarter
and the score is tied
so let's say at the end of those 10
minutes we're still tied which by the
way in the postseason would be epic be
remembered forever if the game goes on
in marathon fashion as it did with miami
and kansas city in some game like in
1971 on christmas day and they affect in
effect played into a sixth quarter it
becomes part of football lore like the
ice bowl played under those conditions
becomes part of football lore but let's
say you're going to another extra period
well then the team that lost the flip
gets to decide
at the beginning of the next period
so you know i won the i won the coin
toss and i took the ball to start the
first overtime now
even if i have the ball when time runs
out the other team is going to receive
at the start of the next period all
right that's interesting we also had a
caller call in yesterday to say that the
opening coin toss of the game that if
you win it and defer to the second half
and get the ball to start the second
half which so many teams do
you not only clearly uh give the ball to
your opponent to start the game but you
would give the ball to your opponent to
start the overtime too
that or you keep it you won the toss i'm
gonna start the game in the first
quarter but now i know in the back
pocket if this game goes to overtime i
start it so at least it's predetermined
from the outset who gets the ball to
start overtime and thus it removes the
coin flip and the yeah the randomness of
such in overtime i kind of i don't mind
that as long as it's a timed period okay
as long as it's not and you know i've
heard people say hey the rule is called
sudden death
okay yeah it was and it was really
exciting when johnny unites did it to
the giants in 1958 when no one had seen
a sudden death game before but just
because that was the rule yes you can
never change it the goal post used to be
on the goal line then kickers got to be
too good yeah you know no no i know i
mean bob i mean we had a 17 games
regular season now we got a 17 week now
we got we had 18 weeks all right i think
we've solved this thing um we've solved
this thing and um i'll run it up the
flagpole how does that sound the the
bottom line is what happens in an
individual game does not determine
whether this rule is good or bad and who
you are rooting for doesn't determine
whether it's good or bad logic should
thank you very much bob okay bye okay
bob let's fix baseball let's go
tomorrow
tomorrow yeah we'll chat tomorrow go
back tomorrow we'll talk tomorrow
this week
bob costas
talk to your mom
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here